[Music]
elizabeth warren's presidential campaign
the most annoying on record expired some
time ago but she remains to lecture
America and you specifically on your
shortcomings
her latest crusade inspired by the
coronavirus is an absolute demand for
nationwide mail-in voting what's
happening right now shows us exactly why
we need a plan for voting safely during
a pandemic now there's a simple fix to
make sure that no American will have to
choose between voting and keeping
themselves safe and healthy all states
should allow Americans to vote by mail
it's easy to vote by mail and in
addition there should be online
registration extended registration
deadlines and expand early voting sounds
kind of reasonable they're less
reasonable over on MSNBC where one guest
argued if you don't want mail-in voting
your murderer you're saying in Wisconsin
one of the most awful things I've ever
seen in my life you know just go you the
extent that what they will go to to hold
on to power and it's all about one
Supreme Court seat in Wisconsin they
will kill people to stay in power
literally literally literally kill
people
unless you're for the Elizabeth Warren
plan you're literally killing people
you've blood on your hands let's take
this seriously for a moment everyone's
afraid everyone's rethinking how we do
things should we do it a new way and
that's okay we should be open-minded why
haven't we had mail-in ballots for the
last 230 years maybe the reason is
mail-in ballots are an invitation to
widespread fraud and manipulation and if
you want to rattle people's faith in the
system that we've had for centuries
maybe you would do that I don't know tom
Fitton thought a lot about he's
president Judicial Watch he joins us
tonight hey Tom
right so so it's just so interesting in
a moment like this people gravitate
towards solutions that make you wonder
particularly all a line behind one
solution you makes you wonder like why
are they all for this I mean maybe it's
gonna day maybe it's not but why are
they for
do you think I think they want to set up
a system that makes it easier to steal
elections they don't want mail-in voting
the way people understand it there's
already widely available absentee
ballots absentee voting available to
Americans and that obviously should
maybe be more widely available if this
contagion continues in the fall but they
don't like that because a lot of the
states or too many of the states
actually require you to send an ID in
with your absentee ballot and they want
to overturn that so this plan is to
overturn the voter ID laws in 35 states
have mailing 2 lists that are dirty we
just sue today in North Carolina they
have according to our analysis about 1
million nearly 1 million inactive voters
most people who hadn't voted since let's
say 2014 so we're gonna start mailing
inactive voters people who died or move
away ballots it's an open invitation for
ballot fraud and a frota fraud and look
the safest way to vote if you want
secure voting is in-person private when
you take that away it's how it's
anything goes and of course they want to
add ballot harvesting to it where they
would allow third parties to go around
bang on doors and collect ballots what
what a nightmare they were you know look
we're destroying our economy we're
limiting our freedoms and now they just
want to blow up our elections and we
can't let that happen Tucker if you take
two I mean first of all I think people
should be allowed to vote
obviously citizens should be allowed to
vote and you shouldn't make it too hard
for them to vote you shouldn't put
barriers up i I actually grew them on
that but if you care about democracy you
want to keep people's confidence that
it's real the right and so you want to
make sure that non-citizens aren't
voting for example but they want to do
the opposite which tells you everything
Tom great to see you tonight thank you